y hablamos entonces de revista de prensa
con rosa pérez masdéu hoy viernes 18 de
marzo rosa bienvenida ya finalizando la
semana empezamos entonces esta revista
de prensa fijándonos como es la
situación al interior de rusia lo vemos
y lo que encontramos en el medio ruso
nóvaya gazeta buenos días raúl
exactamente no nos hemos querido fijar
particularmente en cómo está afectando
esta guerra en el día a día de los
ciudadanos rusos y el nóvaya gazeta hace
un estudio liderado por el periodista
iván healing que se titula cómprame si
puedes en este estudio describen lo que
ya consideran una inminente escasez y
aumento de los precios de consumo
básicos particularmente se fijan en que
no hay azúcar en muchas tiendas rusas y
ahí donde las hay ha aumentado el precio
o incluso está siendo racionado cita al
ministerio de industria ruso este
artículo que señala que es una escasez
artificial creada por los intermediarios
para que aumenten los precios pero de
hecho el periodista responde a esta
afirmación del ministerio de industria
los precios ya han subido hasta casi un
50 por ciento y no está reapareciendo el
azúcar lo mismo sucede con la levadura
también consideran pues alarmante la
situación con el café o la pasta nos
están diciendo reduciendo las cantidades
que vienen en cada uno de los paquetes
también subieron los precios de la
comida de animales los productos de
tecnología y electrodomésticos señala
que ahora vale el doble que el 23 de
febrero amueblar una cocina pero que
realmente lo que preocupa a la gente es
la escasez y la subida de precio en los
medicamentes en los medicamentos
disculpa y en los productos básicos de
higiene esto en el nóvaya gazeta pero
como lo reseña el como los que haya
parada pues en él en este medio raúl
alexander boiko hace un ejercicio
periodístico muy muy típico de
cualquiera situación bélica no se reduce
exclusivamente a russian hoy es un poco
una oda a los soldados caídos viene a
decir pues que no murieron en vano en
este artículo encontramos pues
retratos de distintas personas distintos
hombres que han fallecido luchando en
ucrania déjame leerte parte de la
introducción de este artículo dice
parece que las fotos de estos héroes
vuelvan a la vida cuando se posan
delante de tus ojos antes de leer las
terribles historias sobre los combates
que continúan todavía teniendo lugar
ahora mismo no y precisamente en esta
imagen vemos la foto del sargento álex
gaps en que el artículo nos explica que
murió en una emboscada en un choque
entre pues un batallón ucraniano y ruso
dice que los ucranianos en esta
situación eran muy superiores en número
pero aún así el batallón de gap cerco
logro infligir daños significativos en
las filas enemigas dice que en este
encuentro llegaron a capturar a 13
neonazis así los llama que en el
posterior interrogatorio dieron
información muy valiosa sobre los planes
del enemigo de los nacionalistas de los
ucranianos pues en una zona determinada
y concluye diciendo las nobles acciones
y permitieron seguir con el avance de
las tropas y el cumplimiento de la
misión no lo que decíamos no murieron en
vano y retomando un poco de lo que usted
está hablando hoy el canciller ruso
sérguei lávrov se refirió nuevamente a
una desnazificación de ucrania que tiene
que ser inminente y también digamos una
de las condiciones para que se termine
esta invasión rusa a ese país pero ahora
vemos entonces como lo relata la prensa
extranjera esta situación adentro del
territorio ruso rosa nos fijamos en el
moscú time y el país españa exacto
porque en el país raúl por lo que
estabas diciendo precisamente publican
una crónica del escritor francés
emmanuel carrère al que como dice el
título la guerra le pilló en moscú y el
una de las cosas que explica no del día
a día en la capital rusa es como la
televisión de hecho en la principal la
televisión en el canal 1 de noticias
donde ocurrió la protesta de esta
productora en contra de la guerra donde
normalmente hay programas de
entretenimiento documentales etcétera
ahora mismo él explica como desde su
hotel ve básicamente image de tanques
heridos y constantemente la palabra
nazis nazis nazis no en boca de los
presentadores pero básicamente para
resumir un poco el día a día de sus
amigos y conocidos en moscú dice que
comparten miedo miedo de estar en manos
de un loco de putin que bueno es
discutible si está loco no miedo de ser
espiados dice que se está
reestableciendo el temor el que se vivía
durante el estalinismo miedo de quedarse
atrapados en rusia y vergüenza por estar
bombardeando ucrania en su nombre y dice
que todo el mundo en rusia recuerda cómo
se levantó la noche en la mañana del 24
de febrero igual que sucedió en todo el
mundo comparándolo con el 11 de
septiembre de 2001 y ese ataque a las
torres gemelas y para terminar hacer una
comparación entre dos síntesis por un
lado dice la de putin que lo presenta
bueno presidente de la federación rusa
van a conocer cosas como nunca se han
visto y por otro lado también cita a
dmitri murátov el director de nóvaya
gazeta y premio nobel de la paz dice el
futuro ha muerto no dos perspectivas
completamente
estas de la situación que se está
viviendo en la federación rusa para
cerrar comentamos la portada de la
revista 'time' mira raúl esta revista no
la sacamos aquí recurrentemente pero es
que suele llevar en portada unos
visuales muy espectaculares en este caso
vemos esta foto tomada con un dron es un
trabajo artístico djr y una fotografía
de arte en ilusión ccoo y vemos a la
imagen de una niña ucraniana de valeria
no sé si podemos ver la animación que
también pues ha compartido esta revista
en redes sociales
aquí la estamos viendo y lo que viene a
simbolizar un poco no esta performance
hecha en beef el 14 de marzo es pues el
pueblo ucraniano
apoyando la niñez no siempre esta imagen
ante el futuro de un país de la niñez
ucraniana porque pues muchos de estos
niños como dice la revista han fallecido
y la otra mayoría pues había salido del
país como es el caso de valeria y su
madre que ya se encuentran en polonia
gracias rosa por toda la información nos
vemos el lunes con más revista de prensa
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado